we've all been in quarantine self
quarantined for about a month now
marcel's using this time you know to
hang out with the boys
joey geno and leo when marcel came over
things were pretty rough with the boys
but i'm pretty happy with how things are
going now
[Music]
do you like being in this crazy house
with
choked people yes too much people are
you worried
about the quran virus with your family
my family
everyday home east side so you think
they'll be okay
safe home safe the coronavirus
has affected other parts of our life and
the boys have been homeschooling for two
weeks now
i don't think it's going very well um
they're not very disciplined
it just it worries me like what's gonna
happen with their education
it's difficult homeschooling okay come
on come on don't move
i think it's been like two months since
the boys have all gotten a haircut
and they're looking pretty shaggy right
now stop going so like
aggressive i know my hair looks trash no
it looks good
you ruined it no i didn't ruin it and
you know i think i've got this
no wonder those ladies have attitudes
when they cut your hair if you move too
much i would have to shave your head
okay let me okay i'm sorry i'm sorry
buzz cut
yeah no i'm just kidding okay okay wait
wait wait it's not done it's not done
does not like his hair i feel really bad
leo please open the door no
you have to he flips out his hair looks
what looks so horrible my mom
call my hair again